the end of the road for the president's
impeachment trial a date is now set for
the final vote one that appears set for
acquittal the chances of a conviction
were drastically reduced yesterday when
Republicans deny the Democrats proposal
to call new witnesses and introduce new
evidence the president is set to deliver
the State of the Union before a joint
session of Congress on Tuesday night the
address will come a day before the
Senate will vote mr. Trump is spending
the weekend at his Florida resorts and
Ben Tracy is traveling with the
president Ben good morning good morning
so the president had hoped to be waking
up here in Florida acquitted by the
Senate and we have heard that he is not
happy about the fact that his
impeachment trial is now going to go on
for several more days but Republicans
did stick together and they have blocked
potentially damaging new evidence
against the president a confident Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell left the
Capitol last night after beating back a
last-ditch effort by Democrats to call
new witnesses I send an amendment to the
desk to subpoena John our Bolton
Republicans held firm on all the key
votes mr. Alexander with only Susan
Collins of Maine and Utah's Mitt Romney
siding with the Democrats to hear more
evidence I know you're the greatest
deliberative body in the world but not
even you can deliberate in a trial
without witnesses the house managers
hope to subpoena former national
security advisor john bolton who says
he's willing to testify according to the
new york times Bolton's upcoming book
describes a meeting in the Oval Office
last May in which President Trump
personally pushed Bolton to help
pressure the Ukrainians to dig up dirt
on his political rivals that meeting was
just days after Joe Biden announced he
was running for president
The Times also reported that one of the
president's lead attorneys Patsy Bologna
may have been a witness himself to the
pressure campaign President Trump denies
Bolton's allegations so here you have
the president saying John Bolton is not
telling the truth let's find out let's
put John Bolton under oath but the
president's attorneys argued that
hearing from any witnesses would be
waste of time there's no need for that
because these articles of impeachment on
their face are defective yet even some
Republican senators who plan to vote to
acquit the president believe he did
something wrong
senator Lamar Alexander acknowledges the
president withheld US aid at least in
part to pressure Ukraine to investigate
the Biden's and Florida Republican Marco
Rubio said just because actions meet a
standard of impeachment does not mean it
is in the best interest of the country
to remove a president from office
I still hope they'll do the right thing
and vote to convict now that final vote
to convict or acquit the president will
take place at four o'clock in the
afternoon on Wednesday the president
gives the State of the Union address on
Tuesday night and Senator Lindsey Graham
one of the president's biggest
supporters he said the president would
be wise not to mention impeachment
during that speech Michelle we shall see
Ben thank you so much